We're on problem 38.
Which of the following best
describes the graph of this
system of equations?
OK, so maybe they're
the same line.
Maybe they're parallel.
Maybe they only intersect
in one point-- two lines
intersecting in only
two points.
Well that's impossible.
Two lines, I mean that can
happen with curves, but that's
not going to happen
with lines.
So we can already cancel
out choice D.
OK, now let's look
at these two.
See I have a y here and
I have a 5y here.
Let's multiply this top equation
times 5 and see what
it looks like.
So if you multiply the
left-hand side
by 5, you get 5y.
I'll do it up here.
You get 5y is equal to-- 5 times
minus 2 is minus 10x,
plus 5 times 3 is 15.
So if you multiply the top
equation-- both sides of it--
by 5 and it really doesn't
fundamentally change the line,
the equation might look
different, but the equality
will still hold in the same
universe, which is
essentially that line.
So if you just multiply both
sides by 5, they become the
same equation.
5y is equal to minus
10x plus 15.
So they are the same lines.
So that's A, two identical
lines.
Problem 39.
And they want us to simplify
5x to the third over 10x to
the seventh.
So the easiest way to think of
this, or at least for me--
well, there's a lot of ways
you can do it and
we'll do it both ways.
This is the same thing as 5/10
times x to the third times x
to the minus 7.
1 over x to the 7 is the same
thing as x to the minus 7.
And this is equal to--
5/10 is 1/2.
And then here, we have the
same base and we're
multiplying, so we can
add the exponents.
3 plus minus 7 is minus 4.
So x to the minus
fourth power.
And we could write that as 1/2
times 1 over x to the fourth
or 1 over 2x to the fourth.
And that is choice B.
Now you could have done
it other ways.
You could have said,
OK, let's see.
Divide the numerator and
denominator by 5.
So this would have been 1.
This would have been a 2.
And you say, OK, let's divide
the numerator and denominator
by x to the third.
So this will become a 1.
And x to the seventh
divided by x to the
third is x to the fourth.
You could have done
it that way.
You had 1 over 2x
to the fourth.
Either way.
Or you could have even said--
you didn't have
to go to this step.
You could have said, OK, when
I'm dividing with the same
base, I can just subtract
the exponents.
So 3 minus 7 was minus 4.
Either way.
All of them would have valid
ways to approach this problem.
Problem 40.
This looks like a
simplification.
They write 4x squared minus 2x
plus 8, minus x squared plus
3x minus 2 is equal to.
So the key here is just to
realize that this is a minus.
So you could kind of view it as
a plus minus 1 times this
whole thing.
So we're just going to have
to distribute that out.
So this is equal to 4x squared
minus 2x plus 8.
And now we distribute this
minus over this whole
expression.
So minus times x squared
is minus x squared.
Minus times 3x, positive 3x.
So it's minus 3x.
The minus 1 times negative 2.
Well now they cancel out
and you get a plus 2.
We switch the sign on everything
here because
they're all being multiplied
by this negative 1.
OK, now we can simplify.
So let's take the x squared
terms first. So we have a 4x
squared, we have a
minus x squared.
So 4x squared minus x squared
is 3x squared.
4 minus 1 is 3.
Then let's do our x terms.
We have a minus 2x, we
have a minus 3x.
So minus 2 minus 3,
that's a minus 5x.
And then last we have
our constants.
We have 8 plus 2.
8 plus 2 is 10.
So 3x squared minus
5x plus 10.
And that is choice D.
Problem 41.
OK.
They say the sum of
two binomial-- let
me copy this one.
It's interesting.
The sum of two binomials
is 5x squared minus 6x.
So a binomial is just a
polynomial with two terms. If
one of the binomials is 3x
squared minus 2x, what is the
other binomial?
So this binomial is one of them,
so they're saying 3x
squared minus 2x, and when you
add that to some other
binomial-- and I don't know, let
me just write that as A.
I mean there is no constant
term here and there is no
constant term here, so I'm
assuming that my-- and it has
to be a binomial.
There's only two terms. So I'm
assuming my two terms are an x
squared term and x term because
that's the only terms
that are involved in
both of these.
So let's say my binomial
is Ax squared plus Bx.
This is the mystery binomial.
And their sum is equal
to this up here.
Is equal to 5x squared
minus 6x.
Now let's see what we can do.
Well this is a plus here,
so the parenthesis
really don't matter.
We can rearrange this as 3x
squared plus Ax squared minus
2x plus Bx is equal to
5x squared minus 6x.
3 plus A.
3x squared plus Ax squared,
that's the same thing as 3
plus A, x squared.
And then, minus 2x plus Bx, or
we could switch them around.
That's the same thing as plus
B minus 2-- I just took the
coefficients and added
them together-- x.
I switched them, but we could
have written this in the other
order to begin with-- is equal
to 5x squared minus 6x.
And now you just compare.
OK, 3 plus A-- if you just look
at the x squared terms--
3 plus A has to be equal to 5.
Because that's the coefficient
on the x squared term.
So 3 plus A is equal to 5.
Subtract 3 from both sides.
You get A is equal to 2.
And then we have B minus 2 has
to be the coefficient on x
here, so it has to be
equal to minus 6.
Add 2 to both sides,
you get B.
Minus 6 plus 2 is 4.
So the other binomial, just
substituting that Ax squared
plus Bx, is 2x squared
plus Bx.
Oh, sorry.
This is a minus 4.
Minus 6 plus 2 is minus 4.
So plus Bx.
So minus 4-- that's B-- x.
And that is choice A.
Next problem.
OK, they say, which of the
following expressions is equal
to-- this is problem 42.
And they write x plus 2, plus
x minus 2, times 2x plus 1.
So we have to simplify this.
And remember, order of
operations, multiplication
comes first. So we have to
multiply these two expressions
first. So let's do that.
So this is-- I'll rewrite
this one over here.
x plus 2 plus-- and now
let's multiply this.
When you multiply these two
binomials, you're really just
doing the distributive
property twice.
And let me show that to you.
We could view this as x minus
2 times 2x plus x
minus 2 plus 1.
So I'm just distributing the x
minus 2 times each of these
terms. So I could write this as
x minus 2 times 2x, plus x
minus 2 times the 1.
All right, and now we can just
simplify that by doing the
distributive property again.
So this is x plus 2 plus-- let's
distribute the 2x times
each of these.
2x times x is 2x squared.
2x times minus 2 is minus 4x.
Plus, well, we're
disturbing a 1.
1 times anything
is just itself.
So plus x minus 2.
And let's see what we can do.
We only have 1x squared terms,
so let's write that down.
2x squared.
So 2x squared.
And then our x terms, we
have a plus x, a minus
4x, and a plus x.
So we have 1 minus
4 is minus 3.
Plus 1 is minus 2.
So its minus 2x.
And then, let's see.
We have a positive
2 and a minus 2.
They cancel out.
So we're left with 2x squared
minus 2x, and that's choice A.
Problem 43, I think we
can fit in here.
Let me copy and paste it.
OK, copy it and now
pasting it.
OK, it says, a volleyball
court is
shaped like a rectangle.
Let me draw that.
Well, I didn't want to draw
it filled in like
that, but fair enough.
Shaped like a rectangle.
It has a width of x meters and
a length of 2x meters.
So it's width is x.
Let me write, this could be
x and this would be 2x.
Because this is longer.
Which expression gives
the area of the
court in square meters?
Well the area is just the
width times the length.
So it's just x times 2x, which
is equal to 2x squared.
That's the same thing as 2
times, x times x, which is the
same thing as 2x squared.
And that's choice B.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.